I love Zoom it's my favorite thing ever
it's so funny and easy to navigate and
never it like never glitches ever so now
it's perfect it's wonderful but you know
what else is wonderful is this movie
what does it feel like to be a part of
you will be a part of people's Halloween
Traditions from here on out what does
that feel like
no no that's how it feels the emotion
um but it's crazy to think about I mean
it's really exciting
um kind of unfathomable yeah and like
honored yeah to be involved and you know
I have such fond memories of like
Halloween and this movie coinciding and
like to think that we'll be in those
memories for other people I just can't
process it truly it's something that I
don't think I'll ever really process
until time goes on yeah crazy imposter
syndrome for sure crazy imposter
syndrome yeah not to get deep over here
yeah
that's okay that's okay well I have to
tell you so I got to screen this movie
and my nine-year-old who's home sick
right now watched it with me and she's
obsessed and is I got very cool mom
points that I get to talk to you guys
today so oh my God we'll tell her we say
hi I will tell her you say hi so just
the rave reviews from her are are big
and for people like myself who love the
original you did it justice and it was
so much fun like it was just fun and
that's what we need I that means the
world yeah you guys did it justice like
we have been waiting waiting to hear
that since we booked the movie I think
and that people just like enjoyed it the
fact that you enjoyed it and said you
had fun like we had fun making those
pretty much the objective yeah that was
what we wanted Mission what was it like
on set with some real Legends I mean
you've got Sarah Jessica Parker that I
mean the originals what did that feel
like
well
um
I'm trying to think of a different way
to answer this question than we've
answered it
you can't like it's just unreal I mean
it's
it it doesn't feel really it's just it
does not feel it's weird kind of felt
like we were doing a stage play
sometimes right for me I would like I
felt like we were doing a play and we
were like learned like they were our
like mentors sometimes that's how I
think about it and they would do those
big dramatic monologue scenes and we
were just like there to like absorb it
all yeah that's kind of how it felt yeah
definitely like you learn a lot from
them just being there and watching them
do their work and I mean again in honor
like to be able to be there and witness
that so yeah working with them was
definitely daunting at first but then
you know you realize that they're not
actually scary witches they're really
nice people
with that thank goodness for that did
they give you tips or tricks on how to
get you know how to get in the how to
get in the vibe for this movie
I think it was all in like the watching
yeah like you're just magnetic every
time you walk into the room you're just
like okay we're doing this yeah yeah
they also I feel like a lot of the times
we're very like collaborative especially
on the scenes like when I was just doing
like the kidnapping scene and Kathy was
very like how do you want to do this
physically like I was thinking this
physically but like what feels natural
to you it was cool because we kind of I
felt like we got to have like input yeah
definitely the entire the entire filming
process felt very everybody's opinion
mattered yeah and so if something felt
wrong or uncomfortable or whatever
um it was very easy to just communicate
that and then have it
changed well that's incredible that's
incredible I'm getting the wrap so I
know you guys have a million people to
talk to you but congratulations it's so
good and it's so fun I'm so grateful yes
tell tell your nine-year-old we said
hello and feel better and I hope she
feels better yeah real thanks guys all
right we'll see you soon bye